It looks like Chris Pratt just posted a major
spoiler for Avengers 4 online.
"Oh I'm sorry.
I didn't know how this machine worked."
We're jumping into the spoilers for Avengers:
Infinity War right away, so now's your last
chance to bail.
Still here?
"Let's go."
Stephen McFeely and Christopher Markus, the
screenwriters of Avengers: Infinity War and
Avengers 4: Even More Infinity War Than Before,
have stuck to their guns in saying that the
heart-squeezing deaths you saw in the theater
are real, saying: "the sooner you accept that,
the sooner you will be able to move on to
the next stage of grief."
But in all honesty, fans know better than
to listen to that crappy advice.
And thanks to an accidental slip from Star-Lord
actor Chris Pratt, their optimistic judgement
has seemingly been proven right.
In a recent Instagram post, it appears Pratt
spoiled a part of Avengers 4 by confirming
the fates of Star-Lord and Pom Klementieff's
Mantis, both of whom disintegrated into space
ash after Thanos snapped his Infinity Gauntlet-wearing
hand and got rid of half of the universe's
inhabitants.
Many believed that most of the deaths in Infinity
War would be reversed in Avengers 4, and Pratt
has essentially confirmed that hunch.
So how exactly did Pratt potentially spoil
the events of Avengers 4?
In the most wholesome way imaginable: by wishing
Klementieff a happy birthday on Instagram,
mentioning that he's eager for the two of
them to join forces again for the third Guardians
movie in 2019.
He wrote:
"Happy birthday, Pom Klementieff, whom many
of you know as Mantis!
She's such a unique, talented, and driven
artist.
Can't wait to start shooting Guardians Vol.
3 with her next year!
Hope you're having a good day, Pom!"
Of course, let's be real here: it was pretty
much a given that Star-Lord and Mantis would
return from the grave, since Guardians film
franchise director James Gunn has been candid
about the fact that Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 3 is a done deal.
Tom Holland's Spider-Man, who disintegrated
in Iron Man's arms at the end of Infinity
War, is basically guaranteed to come back
to life as well, since he has an untitled
Spider-Man: Homecoming sequel in the works.
Both Guardians Vol. 3 and the Homecoming follow-up
will launch after Avengers 4, so Star-Lord,
Mantis, and Spidey, plus a few other fallen
favorites, will likely be resurrected in the
film before jumping back into their individual
film series.
At least there's a bright side to Pratt's
accidental plot detail reveal: Tom Holland
isn't alone in spoiling Marvel movies any
longer.
"I have been asking for weeks and weeks if
I can read the script, and every time they're
like 'Nope, because you can't keep a secret.'"
"They just know he's gonna talk about it."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out this other cool stuff we know
you'll love too!